première intervention officielle ce
matin d'arlette laguiller candidate à la
candidature à la présidence de la
république on devrait plutôt dire
maintenant candidate tout simplement à
la présidence de la république puisque
les 500 signatures nécessaires ont été
recueillis par la ligue communiste
ouvrière dont arlette laguiller et le
chef de file
il y aura sans doute plus de candidats
qu'on ne le prévoyait aux élections
présidentielles en annonçant ce matin
qu'elle avait obtenu les 500 signatures
nécessaires
arlette laguiller fait bien la preuve
que la barre n'était pas si difficile à
franchir
le petit obstacle qu'il me fallait
franchir avant de pouvoir donner cette
confirmation est maintenant levé 500
élus essentiellement maires ou
conseillers généraux m'ont promis de
parrainer ma candidature
alors je tiens à votre disposition les
photocopies des lettres et des
engagements de ces mères vous pourrez
consulter si vous voulez me rendre bien
sûr c'est 500 élus sont loin de partager
toutes mes idées mais certains le font
bien sûr d'autres en sont au contraire
éloigné parmi les parrains d'arlette
laguiller s'il ya une majorité d'élus de
gauche
il faut noter toutefois qu'elle ait
obtenu près de 25 appuis parmi des élus
de sensibilité majoritaire alors en ce
qui concerne les autres petites
formations sait déjà que get bouchardeau
elle aussi pour le ps eut obtenu les 500
signatures et que l'extrême droite de
son côté ne semble pas connaître trop de
difficultés
c'est donc déjà une surprise aujourd'hui
que de constater que la nouvelle loi de
1976 qui rendait plus difficile l'accès
aux élections présidentielles
n'empêchera pas finalement les minorités
d'être présente à cette élection
il ya actuellement une trentaine de
candidats à la candidature et il
pourrait donc y avoir à l'arrivée plus
de candidats qu'en 1974 où il était
alors 12